arnaud et exploitants agricoles depuis
2008 à la tête de 130 bovins et 35
hectares de culture un patrimoine
familial qui se transmet de génération
en génération depuis le début du siècle
dernier mais pour arnaud ce n'est pas
simple à seulement sa troisième année
d'exploitation
les difficultés financières s'accumulent
coincé entre ses charges et ses dettes
d'un côté et de l'autre des rentrées
d'argent incertaine dans l'étude
économique j'ai prévu donc on appelle ça
des prélèvements privés
on n'a pas de fiche de paye bien sûr
j'ai prévu 1000 euros par mois je suis
pas très gourmand je pense un mille
euros aujourd'hui
si j'arrive à voir entre 5 et 7 100
euros par mois je suis content je suis
content et le cas d'arnaud est loin
d'être isolé car dans les bureaux de
l'adasea qui accompagnent les dossiers
d'installation à la chambre
d'agriculture
les réponses négatives s'accumulent
faute d'accord bancaire c'est bien que
l'indre-et-loire perd ses agriculteurs
actuellement on est déjà sur une
installation pour trois départs dans le
département bon dit comme ça ça veut
peut-être pas dire grand chose mais en
ramenez je dirais quelque chose de plus
concret c'est à peu près un agriculteur
de moi tous les quatre jours sur un
département
arnaud lui a la chance de pouvoir
compter sur ses parents une aide
financière mais également matérielles et
humaines
la joie de la retraite ce sera pour plus
tard mais bon c'est comme ça moi mes
parents ont eu leur talent et retraite à
35 ans gestion de deux ans estime que je
peux bien travailler encore mais bon
faut pas trop regarder les autres
traités aujourd'hui qui profite un peu
plus qui voyagent plus nous on n'en est
pas encore tout à fait mais tous les
jeunes agriculteurs n'ont pas cette
chance
actuellement se lancer dans une étude
économique sur cinq ans et des plus
périlleux
les prix de reprise sont trop élevés les
fluctuations les différents prix de
vente trop imprévisible et surtout que
deviendra la politique agricole commune
en 2013